leadership and the small phenomena which
tells Anita the city throughout the
don't not in Paris I think what could a
story that eases our feel that at work
some of his prestige if the American
Academy but is currently completely
renewed in France by the regeneration of
which we are two major lines in the work
first in the history of integration in
France in the 20th century and the same
amount of our earth turns over is a
strong interest in quantitative method
and has fantastic
combining with an actual attention to
the construction of social categories
and their impact on the production of
medicine and then you have in the
sources
the two ladies present work have
actually completely intertwined in their
intent or trajectory she has returned to
the bukuvu she has co-written two books
and she has 82 other books and a new
nation has been extremely prolific her
first book is called making shot when
he's talking about ecology of all senses
the inversion of eternity shortened
version of a backseat citation the
particular from contain Paris in the
most Americans in the internet and she
covered with cleverness ever managed
here and be called middle twenty thirty
forty somehow which was released in 2008
I know chromatin a mystery Rosie - I'm
sorry it's amid the 2013 police Donna is
quantitative methods for the external
and with clarity and the way parents can
use mathematics to think about the path
and then she co-wrote with economic view
1990 so this prosecution mentor-mentee
991 gt3 the world the conversation
tonight but before turning superposition
panel mentioned the catalog reviewed
exhibits that she organized so so as you
know you have
tonight of consensus regrets margining
that clear that including humans and me
as we turn an extra extra extra ordinary
book so the winter sent here for about
Paxton and try to do justice to the
question he wanted to ask her and give a
sense of ease interest
his deep interest versus quite
extraordinary book so player first of
all can you tell us a little about your
approach and extent was what my current
history and what can this approach tell
us about the Oracle that was not known
before
prestigious publication and everybody
patient with my English I can't give up
my turtle accent and I hope it will be
too hard
understand me and it is half this
journey and I'm going to do my best to
be to be understood and again so what is
Michael history that is a big question
and I don't want to spend too much time
interrogating but to will explain
Michael history came from immigrant
Affairs who in the beginning of the in
the 80s deliver criticism of the trivial
emitters in the field of history gives
boom Germany and many of Communists
attacked large-scale
underground that they distort reality
until indeed available the
micronutrients placed their health and
smoothness and how people committed
their lives within them I purchased in
the scale of observation they argue that
they are not likely to reveal the
complicated function of individual
relationship within each and every
social Center and the stress is
different from the larger modes that is
what we did with Nicaraguan when we
decided to conduct an intensive survey
among Jews from the city of Los in
novotel the small town located do not a
friend's loss is an industrial city and
have a long history of common emitter we
talk about when you choose a specific
city but one of the main reasons was
inside there were over 1,000 Jews
announced in 1939 to not alert which
made it possible to do in my person
illusions or work one who in some kind
of destroyed
whoo-hoo in other words we decided to
track all of the materials that we could
find on each of them in other words we
approach in this world is to
reconstitute as precise as possible the
trajectory of the jatropha knows we're
living there at the beginning of the
world
how do you do this you must all those
who from that investor did you entitled
the last surface of selenium he acted to
risk using a famous story from home life
digging into the death of their lives
our survey has a similar omission but
musically I fight to hammer it is a
story of 300 families 991 people of
course our refugees are quite different
than universally and his progeny George
he's working on a small train and his
book is a reflection of an English
within us we are not Hamas no none of us
there and our mission is very much
historical rather than personal but our
Pacific tracking work travel people
based on a wide range of sources and
archives and I could reserve you the
sorted if you want to we track their
name everywhere when she told us it
eight times
oh she's apprised sweetie with video
because local friend of God National
Park at control among them to resources
rectified from each person trying to
reduce titute the best of those 1,000
Jews from 1949 Takata what for I believe
a trajectory in the battlefield in the
nineties at the moment when my phony
story was very new and seductive to but
is not the main reason why I adopted
this approach to this specific research
it is mainly
middle of my story extremely well-suited
for the center of execution work
sometimes we think we know but we know
only in the most abstract way which
means we better know that all I can say
better at one of the human souls travel
companion does the horrible thing is the
scale of it is so gigantic
so enormous that it becomes easy to
think of it as something mechanical
anonymous but everything that happened
happened because someone made a decision
to put a trigger to flip the switch to
prove a cattle car door - hi betrayal
nice approach elude us to try to bridge
this gap between the internal impersonal
and oftenly literary approach to the
other coast like under sense and the
abstraction of large numbers the
collective fate of communities and
larger populations and we saw this as a
gap in our understanding
events there were also another
historical basis for our choices for a
long time
history focused concentrated on the
people and the process of who was making
by which I need the historical focus on
the planners implement errors and
executioner's of the workers we have
different place in this interval T for
total time some distracted are silent
even later we choose experiences began
to emerge in the form of testimonies add
element under give yoga called the era
of the witness in the nineteen nineties
survival techniques were operated into
the larger narrative of the war goes
according it a privilege trained in our
understanding of masculine processes but
what are we going to do now the children
are learning from normal biological
business our good is a return to find a
new place of it is the Oracle is already
outside of the trash
and that what while we use mainly relies
on each person and we just so that is
one of the main questions why we put
this number in fact and in the cover of
the title because this is the main
question who is Julie or what is a Jew
Unser's would be theological
philosophical society which is not easy
to provide a simple conservative
questions and to be honest I want to
move because I wanted to try to answer
this question in a history away what is
a new rule is do the question of I
the presentation is one of the main
interest of my historical research from
the beginning of my territory to
summarize there are two different ways
to think that identity issues the social
sciences
some scholars adopted terrorist or a
socialist point of you see that I did
not make the culture ethnic militants
knowledge to give a good example is
routed through our different dish of
aminos of proto synagogue of special
foods into special music some other
scholars we found the constructivist
position that say that identity is just
product of the identification process
you can remember the position of Java
for example who say that it is other who
define someone I love Jewish - others
regard both terms an anti-semitic god
this definition was important
immigration file
where I control beyond cobertura he
worked on the importance of
identification processes but I was not
satisfied with those two British ships
would have to put into their York as you
say to be Jewish what does not have to
be schizophrenic but it helps I don't
know it is a different way to answer
this question but I thought that the
question of who is Jew was fascinating
and how to conserve the specific history
in order to identify the genes of 99 we
choose to use spiritual sources usually
the researchers in France have three
choices first to use the community
sources which are firmly religious and
social but which we whether we are lost
because of their super and analysis of
surnames which will be checked
wonderful that they are not exclusive
Jewish names first remains and multiple
equally different the purpose of the
research to send with June and with no
such a research methodology would over
determine our search member answering to
not only the very question but also
itself or 23rd to use the list of Jews
Brunel during and after the war we try
to convert the frost solution due to
some to some very liberal tiles
Nikola and I appreciate the project
because we found some exceptional record
in the department apart from the Jewish
census of 1940 this is where the letters
addressed to public authorities by the
truth or not
to declare them worst allergy so it is
from consulate earth was unique and in
many respects an accident of history we
couldn't balance and most
Jew declare themselves directly
traversal they came to the console there
are no traces of the processor but no
however was too far from the original
authority to very easy trouble as a
result many iterations were made in
writing and most people I'm going to put
from a few of the most interesting
letters in a while the father declared
that our g20 as a nationality evil but
describes the future as French because
she is born in France at around the same
time a woman wrote to the register
traffic to expect her reticence in
answering she averaged being of Jewish
origin but she protested she went on
French of French parents after her
father had been volunteer in 1874 the
other in 1940 and her servant
not a question I first come to you to
ask your shoes if with all these French
qualities I must be classified among the
Jews who are currently being
investigated by shining light
attractions or self-presentation
the letter is highly revealing and so is
the authorities answer which arrived to
the leaders including because you were
born as use user travel to Paris of
Jewish origin do belong to the Jewish
race consequently the petitioner has
declared perfect the gospel group as a
stadium straighten demonstrates the
through Presley was completely improved
to logical charity and community it is
very dirty to analyze a wide range of
manners to declare was Jewishness with
different marketing from the sensitive
to make advances what they seem to
filter down cover we're vicious missions
above national and race and we are able
to conclude that the majority of June in
us 75% self-identify ratified channel to
the high leaders identification of Jews
and revision happened
the addiction and work continuation of
service early policies in conference
that was not the case but to go back to
a new question a display of research we
were we have some not album and 2016 yes
926 was our starting number in the list
through the through the world an after
the night we were 26 names are mentioned
at least once but we know every
understand what happened to us so we got
further for occur and then we found both
modules directly related to those 936
self are really big surprise occurs I
will just give you an example we were
not sure about big Network and that was
not the case for example
ha ha ha ha ha we knew him pretty well
because was possible
his name was a reserve of the list that
we use the list of Jews lost in the
Sutherland 44 countries solicitude
present acknowledged January 1941
general and to the list of Jews who were
given the yellow star in August 1942 the
list of June arrested and the element of
settlement 42 we have our own remember
because very you stronger we learn to
play soon arrested the list from 410
which left the major
that is the type of documentation that
we use but we thought we actually he was
living alone with his wife because he
was always said that was my work and
without any children so it was very
surprising when we found in the
conversion distance the letter sent by
the server Susie
Franco we discover up there such a child
Judith spent the whole world human and
this was not an isolated case the
naturalization price we found several
five children and sometimes even while
her husband we spent the whole world
without being identified
I don't identify algae from 946 the
normal routine and arrangement work to
memorize this number reflects the
Constitution the tune of not a bootleg
jersey by seventy courage
and Israel identification but the
boundaries of this new powerful and we
tell the story of the 997 map that we
found after we have indeed many people
over 70 Felicia and we found 997 the
very funny
so we were very shocked deteriorated
quickly at the end of the book that is
the story of Joe expose and post-trial
football player subject who's a very
well-known in France lost particular
adores his authority and who were
imprisoned in the Friends of operation
camp in September 1939 because he was
Austrian and considered as any when the
war was declared disma our object on
so like even this one has it seems since
a group work published some other teams
across the back to us we article to
program 1000 people now so resulting
that over that the return is real
important for me there is no pure
scientific the moonship of the
Jewishness and tradition groupies do I
decide on some very pragmatically
friendly show what was a big Jew in the
specific place at a specific room and
that is my job
would you turn whether student trends
can you see that's an overview
these constructive long chapters that
the basic steps in the trajectory guru
you have silicon
okay so we try to follow a step-by-step
tweet like those facing persecution so I
am going to to say everything just just
extremely dance I mean so much I will be
the story and you know it pretty well
Leland suffer much more than the average
Jews in France 487 from the city were
arrested during the war 467 were very
deported and only 18 survived
deportation by the end of the world the
Jewish community of men had been really
reduced to around 500 people this means
that nearly half of messages were
preferred as compared to 25% of Jews in
France as at all the statistics are
telling themselves yet we must remember
that each number in terms of personal to
face wrenching decision and follow the
unit passed a few more years the Jewish
community knows was hit with who falls
at the beginning of the war
face several options which we try to
retrace as you say declare oneself the
truth or not new engines are not we to
return to land as was located no problem
duel for energies stay and get only one
with one's world but at what with
several other parties but to whom
awfully but by separating from one
another and we're welcome questions
which confronted each of the night
recognized one Jimmy knows where are
nothing less than matters of life others
we follow individuals from their
identity questions
that's like for most for a reason to
stay there our disposition
and I have pronounces this disposition
when oh okay
there are two losers down there arrest
and deportation the extermination of
police would expect the road and
forcibly returned to North Attleboro
so I'm not going to survive over but
just say that the originality of our
approach is that we did not necessary at
the winner is of a geographical location
laws which follow the Jews of the two
cities which are living in 1940 didn't
lead to permanent safety so we would be
trapped
later on that interpretation the Jews
who stay in our terminals we're seeing
assorted
an ever growing list of discriminatory
measures our general conclusions are
compatible with most of the right of
these issues but my historical approach
apps to understand the precise details
in fact as frightenin detailed list of
all of the talents these potatoes and
it's taken from the Garden Club Jews who
had been arrested and deported and this
taken from their apartment that started
illustrate the extent to which
persecution has reduced most of latitude
distribution the first very hard part of
the research process evolved for me to
do during the deportation process thank
to the opening of new archives the bad
person cause digitalized even to buy
cigarettes
Historical Museum two years ago we tried
to describe what happened to Dustin from
their arrival at oceans until their
deaths there I attend 467 140 and 108
were registering and health at risk and
that means that more than 75% went
immediately to the gas chambers up to
108 Jews from lands we are registered
and Health Act OSHA came 84% back the
Moodle who's a date of death is new the
quarter died endorsements and 85 by the
end of progress
survival value here and suspect of the
church we didn't work for me anymore
with the archives but for members the
Senate Congress even to the Jews under
the cap and the tune and there are no
streets the professor became members I
am you I am dealing develop a percentage
here but this research had also quite
poetic style and you asked for
additional stirring story so I will give
you one the management they worked with
burger and one sister Omar what water is
a either steak not with his wife that he
stood the Covenant the wife was our
still during the summer 1942 and placed
into traffic for woman but I have yet
ten years old in 1942 poignant we're all
arrested the dude from September
either our network to recap of many in
Belgium
and then deported - oh she's under
groovy of secondary 15 convicted the
different factors are can and went
directly to get to her throughout the
rifle model survival can make eNOS 20:45
estate there as a government open
trilogy versatile tool bar magnet David
Rosenberg and had a pretreatment they
own self declared multi-party there are
only works for the military who didn't
sue to our arrested and deported by her
husband and two of the children of the
second you know I will childe Rowland
and 2019 laws and in our own master of
university system the only survivor was
a last time not on one knows the least
30 said he was the first
and we're ugly stress the other part of
other survivors to by the children were
sent directly to death but that it was
them with a condo unit to vessel to
clean up the roots of the ghetto from
October 1943 - Oh business protocol with
three other teams of laws that we were
self to depression
he was still alive produce twenty four
people we don't know that she isn't
listening he were really lost was
exactly looking back with his wife and
one child according to the list of the
Israelis who lived in north electrolysis
met since May 2014
then from the court they were not
arrested
we could not any of the deportation list
from France invention undoubtedly there
were hidden somewhere in France and
change their identities the last owner
must have no change
he married a woman named Laura and most
Latinos Native artists they wanted to
lose and stay there for two years before
managing to escape to Switzerland in
October 1942 joining Paula's parents who
were living there in the end Switzerland
was only safe location 55 June of laws
succeeded in crossing the border
Estrada still delivers all 55 survived
in 1945 came back to North balloon she
was part tutorial and home as well she
tried to get the death certificate from
the police caught them that had great
difficulty establishing their faith max
came back to and became the head of the
local UJ our premium fishery for the
resistance in on trend the social Jewish
organization what can we do
from these stories the trajectories of
the magnetically so how did you tell me
to generalize from one case to the
others to interpret choices and
decisions made by the different house of
faith in the presentation when silver
family for covers and so many
trajectories so many choices some impact
outcomes decisions the first request to
the network of accountancy finally
trajectory and to morality and
complicity individual I to the rebels
makes it possible to study the Holocaust
from below whatever the scale of
observation direct diversity is the main
conclusion of
one of our goal is to try to eat them
please to understanding these different
actions and outputs
this approach is sometimes called
further programming and we first to
documentation of the victims beliefs and
knowledge in light of their social
networks roots of application
biographical trajectories and that what
we try to do and not just their some
individual stars view that this
relationship between the individual
stories and the future can you tell us
what you are expecting movement
education in a way the data
commendatory to combine my poetry with
communication micro histories actually
develop individual video stories
trajectories and education is about new
group so how do you combine us to and
so the aim of our work to attract the
dilemmas faced by the truth knows not as
technological phenomena but rather as
choices develop not only on the
particular context but also on the
social and democratic characteristics of
those who make them so we need
fortification for that coming
configuration structured group
allegations here right I think I hope to
do - originally that is why we choose to
respect to explain the circumstances
that we usually associate with the
similarity of sovereignty we explicitly
identified information while health
hydrazines the etiology of Jewish
experience is not it is a matter of your
furniture while at the same time
expanding the conception of social
we tried to talk but it is possible
under there the social software occur in
from Canada some behavior during the
genocide and especially during the war
the protective approach allow us to give
some research that are not served on a
strictly individual Muslim we try to
explain how socially 413 waiting on the
individual choices people made clear we
spoon prosecution for example we could
identify the main characteristics of the
people we decided to stay in note and
the people we decided to go what is
matter with potential
the reserve which they are jealous
weren't welcome you don't know why once
they determine what is the main
characteristic
is everything playing whoa whoa
but that was amazing yeah disco is very
good matter together
yeah but it's my job to make Jewish
hi Joe what a play
just one it will never see direct at
church workers issues you have to have
frequent balance juice winner but I mean
to me
the biggest thing was the size of
funnies the Moche that you have I mean
the question is really important because
they must meet that for almost everyone
as I told you the wrong appearance was
terrible
according to the census made after the
october 1942 there were just 13 jews not
before settlers there were 300 still
surveillance
so let me back up to it listen to
explain this research we examine the
impact that the finest social and legal
status have to the decision to stay for
free and also write as the virtual truth
woman the most vulnerable a winner
whether wisdoms began to feel however
the lecturers household was the greater
enlightenment of remaining
not is one side during flight
isolation play predictable rustling when
were considers the number of arrests
then Kashuk networks could be averted
what could generalize this insight to
complete that whether this time family
collections can be an asset the family
for Jewish immigrants they become less
adventure land an instance of separation
suggestions I give you some other
example of the remotest of the
quantitative approach I don't want to be
too low because I see the time is
running so as you see micro analyst is
here on small town is to do it
vertically
history and this is also very property
values a lot of managers okay so
actually as a reference is one of the
one of the major question that is raised
by the
three is our typical predicts is in one
way non-students this night so at the
very specific location minutes very
clear that even though it's nothing
so basically place at a specific time
how can you know about that what was not
tell us about the trajectory of
in fact micro history tends to focus on
outliers rather than looking for the
average unlimited determined by the
application of
I mean my proletariat brought the term
normal exception is often used to
characterize this perfectly it means
that none of us show a full hand of God
seeing what is usually kept hidden from
the outside world
we realize that our focus has only even
under normal Egyptians so in one segment
of society are considered Austria trend
and even doctors there might be in
motorcycles at the center of attention
and freely accepted in their daily
affairs my point is that you are totally
right is not at all representative and
friends and I think nearly half
14 a staggering 25% of duty friends as a
whole are proposed well not at all
teachers are afraid of Antietam but to
write the story from below the question
is to understand why not is not a battle
that is common questions how can we
understand
in craftmas of the three main reasons
first reason the number foreigners in
the community as at the national level
the deposition rate was 70% of fractures
and 43 process for foreign Jews in us
this rate we're respectively 35 percent
of Frank Jews and 59 cents withdraw
foreign Jews which suggests that
nationality still offer protection the
less than the national average and this
is a consequence of the stages of not
part of the Forbidden Zone lost was
considered by Germans as part of the
vegetarian the only national Jews not
there with their genitals fractions
we're considered as forever because
those were connected to danger after the
third round of the government was to
reduce certain Jews left not all where
where judges soon
all of the users working for vigorously
by the authorities are not living with
officials were very aggressive and to
carry out some cities of the Jewish
population on crossing economic and
financial discrimination imposing
lyrical and radical and caricatures for
meditation so police commissioner of
laws with documents seemed very
receptive to the German orders and
sometimes God help them he anticipated
their turn there was literally no
evidence of Jews finally people of
support from the knowledge which
population of us who see the university
a foreigner that equally rivals polish
writer the client blood property
community we are not at pool the number
of branches the mutilations the back
alley is one of the lures so the wish we
were to see not at the office of
education to in order
I am not decidable of an astronomers who
have the chair are disappointed Steve
and establish this Madera economic and
social history the result of that work
to the form of thousands of detail or
Nebraska conceived of a species of a
student user would definitely we will
complete image of the economic and
social history of early modern France my
conception is really totally different
I see the perversion of the law library
produce effects rightly and the
methodology of all usefulness we might
approach anything new jokes and
questions identification we can
sweetie and go to questions so now I'm
going to put its Vista from one of her
attacks and Christian was mentioning
involved in Genesis studies in the
winter of 2006 by the rate of Jewish
survival and it is hurtful that
Professor was encouraged to work the
author mentions all the factors for
survival what are the factors in this
statistic situation that made survival
more as 90 and so the author was going
leave Germany first the intensity of the
German injury the local aid to the
Germany for the role and symmetry
attitudes the facilities are ways to use
and and and so forth so Paxton the
person was
because these are below me us to do some
fortifications even on this specific
subject which was not easy 45 that 550
of the old-growth was not an easy way to
do and this was sort of a pioneer
article about that but the most
important contribution to promote we do
well to warn all the workers percent
using the traditional methods of
historians and I am convinced that the
methods of social historian can define
muchos of research but due to the
exceptional part there are also objects
you get permits reverends and reverends
- this is also what I learned from his
work on machine there is no reason to
why the history of this Canyon we serve
both are tools that have water his
talent exactly what he did and just knew
this would work as specific external so
what is interesting in this specific
article is to speak about survivors and
that people to ask the question of who
survived and what to do that the cities
are immature the regression logistic
notice for the body weight also measure
265 logistic regression
is a type of regression element analysis
of statistical methods used for
predicting the outcome of a very
different variables based on the work of
our rarest writer logistic regression
might be used predict whether a patient
has a given disease based on observed
characteristic observation age gender
body mass without a very good test
mission another graph might be to
predict whether of voters will vote
Democratic
again Sarkozy or below based on age
income gender race state of residence
but in previous image enhancer so that
one first did about arrival what we
could show along with the signal sense
to reduce the presentation
if only wizard survived or not there are
a lot of steps during the process of
persecution and each of them is
determined by factors which vary from
state to state to be multi treated the
declaration process is determined mainly
by age yoga are not terrible death the
more color you are the more time
yourself you are going to do the
limitless process by the sight of me as
we sew together the arias ionization
process by nationality the deportation
process by location and countries'
fragmented gender doesn't play any role
until the very end
we survived
fifteen men came back and just three
woman so their gender is right this
shows you how the process of persecution
can't be for my proton you just analyzed
as a final result to survive or not but
surely understand as a trajectory
therefore my own work on the formally
formalization of the different
trajectories of persecution
speaking of the quantitative average but
I'm not going to do segregation
tell us a little more about your
occasion with in Mexico with other
historians use the research that the
students of the description of the
European Jewry have explored numerous
terms of investigation the perfect if
deployed and historians have ranged from
professional studies to more African
biographies and more recently
researchers have adapted the more micro
produce investigating hood groups of
perpetrators family trajectories the
reverse the history of people can't a
city or abridging I wanted to we
recently published majors from a
communal spirit which all adult might
approach Christopher Coney for example
in his last book entitled remembering
survival and least Great War I from
Madonna and studied the hood together
start started they tell me to of Jewish
survival strategies and what I want to
say is that one of the main goals of the
rifle approach is to integrate
strategies and agencies into the
historical trend of the world we regard
the Jews brought from out whether the
issue question is right around Italy
down during the world and the answer is
not
it is easy to know why and when to be
producer who allergies and we are go to
stay on the macro level one can observe
the supervisor to stay done but the
process of making the decision computer
better of my problem let's another
example of the recent work America that
you must know of course his goal is to
trace the origins of genocide
it's a complexity of internal
declarations of our new time span little
toe which are located in mr. condition
the population of system of mixed Jewish
polish Ukrainian and that of tries to
understand the education of its Jewish
relatives by Lazaro dress was assisted
by local collaborator and the occasion
for each Polish population
different investments to my father who
the delimitation of Terra Mystica
champion supposed to be a constitutive
solution of a social space and the
decision facing considers a better in
the space none of us like significantly
highlights the dynamics of social
relations of new victims executioner's
advisement this contribution produced on
interactions and that is one of the main
points of my own historic advantages and
the last one is the issue of societal
tracks
I am currently organizing a big
conference on micro history of the
orifice which is going to have a Paris
next December we put out a call for
papers and guess what we received more
than 150 problems to reduce interest you
are God do
so
resolution this is the track of these
trucks and Mark III attack
for our charity the ways of doing and
frightening story but I have also a
brand new project brand-new so very
bright very being and one of your
colleagues very carefully that is our
the Columbia was very important to me
deciding whether it was not totally
insane - little bit insane but I would
like to do all of the Jewish people of
push down to do something at the
beginning of the twenties and track them
all over the world
okay so my big questions is to
understand how the Holocaust affect the
hierarchy and the organization
opportunity within migration genocide
deportation and reconstruction
I will try to follow each member of this
3,000 people community to build a
trajectory model and what really
about a project that I don't know I'm
terrible
that's what I like
those rules check everything there is
the migration for tech more than any
other pattern in actual at the French
case show - my way to France did not
mean escape from destitution whoo is
movie where the solution YouTube is act
with bring me to another place Estrella
a squeezed mental state Israel but the
long beach pool difficulties and I have
work to do so I hope I will be able to
present a new project in itself a couple
of years
oh there's going to be before seniors so
we're going to stop questioning now and
we need to redirect what person
person-centered approaches in quite
extraordinary extraordinary progress you
know demonstrated is extremely
interesting presentation so we